this episode is made possible by
curiositystream
a few weeks ago i announced that i'd be
putting an exclusive series about
fascism on a new platform
i got a lot of comments on that video
from people saying they were
disappointed that the series wouldn't be
on nebula
i've heard you guys loud and clear from
now on any exclusive content i make will
be exclusive to nebula
that includes a new and revamped series
on the resurgence of fascism around the
world
which will premiere in the coming weeks
you can get free access to my content
and the rest of nebula absolutely free
when you sign up for curiosity stream at
the link below
[Music]
if you've been following this channel
for a little while you are probably
aware of my perspective on capitalism in
the united states
with effectively unchecked power
corporations have reached their
insidious tentacles into each and every
corner of society
choking out competition from family
enterprise buying politicians and
amassing obscene wealth for their owners
and investors
trying to push back against such forces
by creating more just systems can seem
like a daunting prospect
especially when it comes to operating
within this existing predatory structure
the modern corporation offers its
workers absolutely zero say in how the
company is run
beholden instead to wealthy investors
and shareholders most jobs are
democracy-free zones
you do what you're told you accept what
you're given and you don't speak up when
something could be done better
the ideal solution would be to dismantle
this oppressive and exploitative system
and build a more democratic nation
instead
but for the moment that seems unlikely
without tearing everything down
and replacing the capitalist economic
framework entirely with a more humane
and egalitarian one
is it even possible to efficiently
produce and distribute goods or services
in a way that's fair to the people on
the payroll
the workers putting in their time and
energy from nine to five
is it possible to have a democratic
workplace that puts real power in the
hands of those who provide the labor
as it turns out yes there is a setup
that can not only compete but offer
exceptional service and democratic
working conditions
it's called a worker co-op as the name
suggests a worker cooperative is a type
of autonomous business model that puts
its workers and the communities they
live in before anything else
to make this happen rather than being
run by a single owner or ceo
co-ops are controlled democratically
each member gets a vote either for the
explicit determination of operational
structures and how they are treated
or for the election of a board of
directors to do the same what's more the
workers themselves collectively own the
company
this system is very flexible and can be
used for any type of business
from taxi drivers to web developers they
are the quintessential social enterprise
putting collective good above personal
gains often operating as non-profits to
guarantee near absolute freedom from
executive greed
co-op members often find themselves
possessing a level of dignity and
quality of life
unattainable by traditional employees
along with high job stability and
opportunities to develop new skills
and membership is open to anyone willing
to accept certain responsibilities
regardless of discrimination they may
face elsewhere on
top of all this worker co-ops can be
more stable than profit-driven
corporations
reliably staying afloat in times of
economic turmoil which have become
worryingly common in recent years
you never see a cooperative bank needing
to be bailed out with taxpayer money
because they don't have to undertake
risky financial endeavors in a
never-ending quest to maximize profit
instead they simply exist as a safety
net for normal people
providing loans and credit at reasonable
rates so those with savings can
indirectly help their neighbors without
thus addressing economic inequality in
poor neighborhoods
while the estimated number of currently
existing co-ops in the us is fairly
small
the democratic workplace model has been
continually rising in popularity over
the decades
especially in recent years as
traditional employment has become less
stable
financially feasible and pleasant by
pooling people's expertise
starting a worker co-op can be easier
than starting a typical business
and they've been pretty successful too
more than just staying out of the red
the average american cooperative makes a
6.4 profit without sacrificing
sustainability
as you might expect these co-ops are far
more commonplace outside the states
most notably in italy and spain in fact
the seventh largest company in spain is
a worker cooperative
let's put things into perspective with a
specific example ocean spray
if you've ever shopped for groceries at
a supermarket in the u.s
odds are you've seen their products
sitting on store shelves in the juice or
canned fruit aisles
they're arguably the most recognizable
cranberry brand in the country
and they were the very first to produce
cranberry juice commercially back in the
1930s
it's somewhat ironic that the biggest
name in cranberries a quintessentially
american fruit native to the continent
and a mainstay of the traditional
thanksgiving dinner
foregoes participation in the equally
american practice of employee
exploitation
but just how well have they managed far
from being unable to grow big enough to
stand against the corporate competition
ocean spray has flourished today they're
the largest producer of cranberries in
the world
with over a billion dollars in annual
sales yet all this financial success has
not compromised their commitment to fair
compensation
the full 100 of all profits the business
generates are distributed right back to
the farmers
no shareholder dividends necessary and
cranberry farmers especially deserve the
metaphorical fruits of their labors
given that the wolf spiders often used
as natural pest control end up crawling
all over their bodies whenever they
flood the bog for harvesting
let's take another example when my wife
and i moved to our current home
we were surprised to see that we could
get our electricity through a worker
cooperative
we're always excited to support
democratic operations so we signed up
united cooperative services founded in
1938
has been serving texans for decades and
now represents over 62
000 people in 14 counties as a worker
co-op
united is not a privately owned company
it doesn't have wealthy shareholders or
investors to placate
instead it's a non-profit and owned by
the workers and consumers it serves
that means there's no predatory profit
motive workers get paid
fairly and any profits get reimbursed to
consumers or are spent on projects to
improve the lives of everyone involved
with the company
for example instead of lining the
pockets of some billionaire executive
united spent excess money to build a
network of solar panels so they could
offer
renewable energy to consumers at a lower
price than traditional energy companies
but the benefits don't stop there every
united co-op employee is entitled to a
vote in board of directors elections
as are all of the consumers who get
their electricity from united
leadership is democratically elected and
held accountable to ensure that both
workers and customers
enjoy the benefits of a more
representative operation that's the
thing that really stands out about
worker co-ops
the fact that they're not driven by a
profit motive but simply by the goal to
provide their workers and customers with
the service their business offers
united cooperative provides electricity
ocean spray provides cranberries
this is in stark contrast to typical
corporations whose primary goal is to
make money
and whose second or third consideration
is to provide a good service
and it's not like worker co-ops are seen
less favorably by their consumers than
traditional companies
in fact co-ops are often much more
highly rated than their profit driven
counterparts
it's almost as if simply providing a
service without trying to exploit your
workers
and squeeze as much money as you can out
of each customer is a good business
model
who would have thought so few american
workers have any idea what
non-exploitative work looks like
we're so conditioned by the terrible
options we're given that we can't fathom
a system in which we actually have a
voice or a say in how things are done
imagine being able to vote for your
managers imagine being paid a fair wage
and knowing the company you work for
isn't exploiting you your co-workers or
the community you serve
that's what every company in america
should look like the sad truth is that
it's about as far away from our reality
as it could possibly be
it's encouraging to see a high-profile
worker co-op like ocean spray
flourishing even in today's
hyper-capitalist economy
as more and more workers become
disaffected by the soul-crushing grind
of the corporate treadmill
hopefully the cooperative model can gain
a greater foothold on the economic world
stage
no system is perfect but co-ops put
power and progress back into the hands
of the many
and that's certainly better than the
system we have now where the gulf
between wage slaves and their corporate
overlords grows ever wider
the pockets of the wealthy growing
deeper and deeper workplace democracy is
a tool which can help people overcome
this seemingly insurmountable obstacle
on the path to health happiness and job
satisfaction
and putting this tool to widespread use
could lead to deeply beneficial change
in the lives of millions of hard-working
people throughout america
and around the world
if you've been watching my videos for a
while now you'll have noticed that
youtube has been demonetizing a lot of
them
that's why some of my creator friends
and i teamed up to build nebula a
streaming platform built by and for
youtubers like me so we don't have to
worry about demonetization
since nebula is all about creating
thoughtful content we've partnered with
curiositystream
an established streaming platform with a
solid track record of caring about great
educational content and the financial
security of those who produce it
curiosity stream is an online streaming
service with thousands of non-fiction
titles from some of the best filmmakers
in the game
you can find tons of great episodes like
the future of work which offers a
fascinating look at what our jobs could
be like in the decades to come
as educational creators ourselves we
love curiositystream
so we've worked out a deal where if you
sign up for curiositystream at the link
below you'll also get access to nebula
100 free
for a limited time curiosity stream is
offering 26 off their annual plan
that's less than 15 bucks a year for
both curiosity stream and nebula
which in my humble opinion is a pretty
great deal since we're all stuck inside
anyway
why not spend some time learning about
fascinating topics on curiositystream or
check out nebula's exclusive content
including my upcoming series on the
resurgence of fascism you can also watch
all my videos as they were intended ad
free
there really is something for everyone
and by signing up at the link below
you're helping us produce
more content without the fear of
demonetization give curiosity stream a
shot
and get free access to nebula when you
sign up using the link below
it really does help support my channel
and educational creators all across
youtube
if you enjoyed this video and you'd like
to see more like it consider subscribing
to stay up to date with my latest
episodes
if you hated it go ahead and drop a
thumbs down you can check out my
previous episodes by clicking the links
on your screen
thanks for watching and i'll see you
next week
you